Music.
Herzlich willkommen zu unserer neunten Folge Dicke Bretter.
Wir sind heute hier, um mal wieder um dieses schöne Thema EU-Politik zu sprechen.
Und heute sind wir wieder mal zu zweit beziehungsweise zu dritt.
Zusammen mit mir ist heute da Constanze. Hallo. Hallo Constanze, schön, dass du da bist.
Und Elisa kann heute leider nicht
da sein und deswegen haben wir uns Svea eingeladen. Hallo Svea. Hallo.
Und ja, wir sprechen heute wieder über EU-Gesetzgebung.
Wir haben ja irgendwann mal angefangen darüber zu sprechen und uns den Kopf
darüber zerbrochen, was so die ersten Schritte sind.
Wir sind nicht ganz bis zum Trilog gekommen und die Chatkontrolle lässt da auch
noch so ein bisschen auf sich warten.
Und deswegen dachten wir, wir spulen jetzt mal vor und sprechen heute mal darüber,
was denn eigentlich passiert, wenn so ein Gesetzgebungsprozess abgeschlossen
ist und wie das Ganze dann auch umgesetzt wird.
Und deswegen haben wir, habe ich gerade schon kurz gesagt, SWEA heute hier.
SWEA ist bei der GFS und kümmert sich genau um dieses Thema.
SWEA, magst du mal erzählen, wer du bist und was du mit Umsetzung von EU-Gesetzen
zu tun hast? Ja, sehr gerne. Ich freue mich sehr, hier zu sein.
Vielen Dank euch beiden.
Ich bin Svea, ich arbeite bei der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte und leite
dort ein Projekt, das Center for User Rights heißt.
Das Center for User Rights bündelt auf der einen Seite Projekte,
die die GFF schon länger am Laufen hatte im Bereich Plattformregulierung und
Durchsetzung von Nutzerinnenrechten,
aber hat dazu nochmal einen neuen strategischen Fokus, nämlich die Durchsetzung
von Nutzerinnenrechten unter dem Digital Services Act.
Und der Digital Service Act ist der große neue Rechtsrahmen für Online-Plattformen
in der Europäischen Union.
Der letztes Jahr in Kraft getreten ist und kurz davor zu Ende verhandelt worden ist.
Und der auf der einen Seite quasi die grundlegenden Haftungsregeln für Online-Plattformen
upgedatet hat, aber vor allem auch viele neue Rechte für NutzerInnen geschaffen hat.
Und die möchten wir jetzt nutzen und einfordern und durchsetzen.
Lass mal kurz über die GFF noch reden. Also diese Center gehört zur GFF.
Die ist ja, also generell, die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte ein bisschen
mehr in aller Munde, weil die einfach, glaube ich, ziemlich viele Erfolge zu
verzeichnen hat. aber auch an sehr vielen Fronten kämpft mittlerweile.
Sag mal ein paar Sätze dazu, wer die jetzt noch nie gehört hat. Was macht die GFF?
Und wie ist sozusagen in diesem ganzen Sammelsurium an wichtigen Themen diese Center da verortet?
Ja, die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte ist ein Verein. Wir sitzen in Berlin
und machen allererster Linie strategische Prozessführung.
Das heißt, wir versuchen, politische, gesellschaftliche Themen durch die rechtlichen
Mittel, die uns zur Verfügung stehen, anzugreifen oder zu stärken oder nach
vorne zu bringen oder auch weiterzuentwickeln.
In vielen Fällen heißt es, dass die GVF Verfassungsklagen oder Verfassungsbeschwerden schreibt.
Da ist die GVF auch sehr erfolgreich. Es gibt viele Beispiele von erfolgreichen
Verfassungsbeschwerden aus verschiedenen Bereichen.
Equal Pay, aber auch im Bereich Überwachung, Grundrechte sozusagen in verschiedenen
Bereichen des Lebens und der Gesellschaft.
Und dazu kommen aber auch noch mal so ein paar speziellere Themen und NutzerInnenrechte
würde ich sagen ist eins davon, wo die GFF eben seit vielen Jahren dran ist,
eben auch durchaus über strategische Klagen, auch über politische Arbeit,
also klassische Policy-Arbeit und jetzt eben mit dem Center for User Rights
nochmal ganz gezielt der Versuch den DSA nutzbar zu machen und NutzerInnenrechte
mit Mitteln des Rechts durchzusetzen.
Und vielleicht nochmal, wenn man jetzt ein bisschen ein Bild hat von der GFF.
Es geht ja um die Durchsetzung von Rechten. In vielen Rechtsbereichen,
das begleitet mich eigentlich schon seit Jahren, ist das so ein bisschen die Achillesferse.
Man hat vielleicht ein gutes Gesetz, das ist jetzt egal, ob es auf der EU-Ebene
ist oder in Deutschland, aber nach so ein paar Jahren stellt sich raus,
die Durchsetzung ist nicht allzu doll.
Dann entdeckt man sozusagen Schwierigkeiten oder vielleicht auch Phänomene,
die man vorher nicht antizipiert hat oder dass sich die Betroffenen,
die bestimmte Pflichten haben durch die Gesetze, irgendwie so rausschlingen können.
Was ist der Hauptfokus dieses Centers, wenn wir jetzt den DSA meinen,
also den Digital Services Act?
Der Hauptfokus ist die Aufsichtsarbeit, die eigentlich Aufsichtsbehörden tun
müssten, also die Europäische Kommission und nationale Aufsichtsbehörden,
über die können wir später noch sprechen.
Das sozusagen da wirklich drauf zu schauen, was sie eigentlich machen.
Machen die die Arbeit, die sie tun sollten? Halten sie große Tech-Unternehmen?
Ziehen sie sie zur Verantwortung, diese neuen Regeln, die es jetzt gibt,
umzusetzen und das tatsächlich richtig zu machen? Das ist eine gigantische Aufgabe,
auch für Aufsichtsbehörden.
Das heißt, unser Versuch ist da eigentlich, auf der einen Seite den DSA kritisch
zu begleiten, weil wir auch nicht alles am DSA positiv finden,
aber vor allem eben diese Aufsicht zu begleiten und da im Grunde genommen auch
selber durchzusetzen und selber zu beaufsichtigen und selber dafür zu sorgen,
dass die großen Unternehmen diese neuen Rechte einhalten,
NutzerInnen in den Vordergrund stellen.
Und das ist natürlich so ein bisschen eine Sisyphus-Aufgabe. Also das ist viel zu tun.
Das ist zum einen Sisyphus, klar. Das ist einfach umfassend, aber...
Da könnte jetzt ja jemand fragen, was legitimiert euch? Also warum kommt jetzt
hier so ein Verein und sagt, ich gucke jetzt hier auf die Rechtsdurchsetzung.
Also wie seht ihr da, warum seid ihr euch da berufen?
Das Recht legitimiert uns eigentlich. Das Recht schafft bestimmte Möglichkeiten,
Dinge durchzusetzen und die wollen wir nutzen.
Und letztendlich ist, wie du schon gesagt hast, jedes Recht nur so gut wie die
Durchsetzung und das ist zum gewissen Grad auch eine gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe.
Also klar, es gibt Aufsichtsbehörden, die da eine Verantwortung haben,
aber wir sind natürlich auch alle eigentlich gefragt, wenn wir Rechtsverstöße
sehen, dann können wir dagegen vorgehen und sollten es auch tun, denke ich.
Vielleicht machen wir jetzt nochmal so prozessual einen Schritt zurück in dieser
ganzen EU-Gesetzgebung. Du hast gesagt, du hast letztes Jahr verabschiedet und
kurz danach in Kraft getreten.
Was passiert also erstmal vielleicht zwischen diesem Verabschiedung und dem Inkrafttreten?
Was ist der Grund, warum das meistens nicht gleichzeitig passiert?
Das wäre glaube ich so das Erste, was wir uns einmal anschauen können und was
passiert jetzt im Fall von dem DSA, aber vielleicht auch beispielhaft für andere
Gesetze dann, wenn so ein Gesetz in Kraft tritt?
Ja, was zuerst passiert ist sozusagen die Verkündung, das heißt das Gesetz wird
im offiziellen Journal der Europäischen Kommission quasi der Gazette veröffentlicht,
vergleichbar mit dem Bundesgesetz,
Bundesanzeiger genau.
Genau und dann gibt es einen Zeitrahmen und der wird in dem Gesetz vorgeschrieben,
den sozusagen sowohl die regulierten Unternehmen als auch staatliche Stellen, Behörden etc.
Nutzen können und müssen, um sich darauf vorzubereiten und sozusagen das Gesetz umzusetzen.
Beim DSA war es glaube ich so, dass der letztendlich dann im Oktober, November 2022.
Verabschiedet wurde, veröffentlicht wurde und dann die ersten Fristen für die
allergrößten Plattformen im August 2023 gegolten haben.
Das heißt auch da gab es so ein gestaffeltes Vorgehen.
Der Ansatz war zu denken sozusagen, die besonders großen Plattformen tragen
besonders große gesellschaftliche Verantwortung, deswegen bekommen die weniger
Zeit die wichtigsten Sachen umzusetzen, alle anderen haben ein bisschen mehr Zeit.
Das heißt, vollends in Kraft getreten ist der DSA dann im Februar diesen Jahres.
Und was dann nochmal dazu kommt und da kommt es ein bisschen darauf an,
ob wir über eine Verordnung oder eine Richtlinie sprechen, ist die nationale Umsetzung.
Das heißt, Richtlinien müssen immer umgesetzt werden in nationales Recht.
Das kann lange dauern. Das sind oft komplizierte, langwierige Prozesse.
Zum Beispiel die Copyright-Richtlinie. Ich will gar nicht wissen,
wie lange die Durchsetzung in Deutschland gedauert hat, aber es hat gedauert.
Viele Monate. Viele Monate und Verordnungen gelten in der Theorie sofort.
Aber tatsächlich nur in der Theorie, weil natürlich DSA, gutes Beispiel,
letztendlich doch viele Strukturen geschaffen werden müssen auf nationaler Ebene,
um es überhaupt umsetzbar machen zu müssen.
Also ganz basic überhaupt schon mal die Frage, wer ist denn die Aufsichtsbehörde?
Die muss benannt werden, dafür braucht es ein Gesetz. Und das war in Deutschland
das Digitale-Dienste-Gesetz, das mit ziemlich viel Verspätung im Mai abgeschlossen
wurde und in Kraft getreten ist.
Oder vielleicht auch Juni in Kraft getreten, aber Mai, Juni.
Und tatsächlich damit sozusagen drei Monate später dran war als der DSA.
Das heißt zum Beispiel in diesen drei Monaten gab es keine Aufsichtsbehörde in Deutschland.
Das heißt wir hatten keinen Counterpart, aber auch NutzerInnen oder auch Unternehmen
hatten sozusagen auch niemanden, an den sie sich wenden konnten in der Zeit.
Ich fasse jetzt nur nochmal kurz die Abkürzung zusammen, weil wir die bestimmt
jetzt noch benutzen werden.
Also DSA ist der Digital Service Act, also die Verordnung der EU und DDG,
das ist das digitale Dienstegesetz, was nur für den deutschen Raum sozusagen
gilt, was ein bisschen später in Kraft getreten ist.
Also die werden wir vielleicht benutzen, wenn es jemand diese Abkürzung hört.
Das Allerschlimmste ist, dass der DSA auf Deutsch als digitales Dienstegesetz
übersetzt wurde, was natürlich überhaupt nicht hilfreich ist,
weil es ja eigentlich was anderes ist. Aber deswegen, genau.
Um Pflichten für bestimmte Online-Plattformen. Es geht aber auch um neue Transparenzregeln,
die sozusagen für die Nutzerinnen, aber auch für alle gesellschaftlichen Gruppen sinnvoll sind.
Und es geht um Moderationsentscheidungen und die Widersprüche,
die man dagegen einlegen kann.
Also das ist sozusagen dieser Rahmen, der vorgegeben wurde.
Und vielleicht sollte man dazu wissen, der Blick war am Anfang sehr stark die
Europawahl, weil die Angst davor, dass es Manipulationen geben könnte,
sehr viel Falschinformationen, die war groß.
Aber letztlich hätte natürlich für die Europawahl wegen des späten Inkrafttretens
hier nicht Wirkung entfaltet.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch eher ein dickes Brett. Wir werden lange damit zu tun haben.
Deswegen würde ich ganz zu Anfang nochmal fragen wollen, wie sinnvoll...
Wie sinnvoll hältst du die Regelung der Verordnung? Ist das ein gelungenes Gesetz?
Klar, praktisch wissen wir noch nicht so sehr viel, aber sind die Regeln,
die da erstmal theoretisch bestehen, sinnvoll und wo sind Schwächen,
die du schon siehst, bevor ihr überhaupt die Arbeit richtig anfangen könnt?
Also die Geschichte vom DSA fängt eigentlich vor knapp 30 Jahren an.
Also die Europäische Kommission hatte mit der E-Commerce-Richtlinie quasi Ende
der 90er Jahre oder vielleicht war es auch 2000 einen grundlegenden Rechtsrahmen
für Online-Dienste in der Europäischen Union geschaffen.
Und es war relativ, ist schon relativ lange klar gewesen, dass das mal abgedatet
werden sollte und vielleicht nicht mehr so hundertprozentig zum 21.
Jahrhundert und im Internet und den ganzen Diensten und Apps und Produkten,
die seitdem im Internet gebaut worden sind, dass das vielleicht nicht mehr so
ganz passt. Das heißt, das war das eine Bedürfnis, quasi diesen grundlegenden
Rechtsrahmen abzudaten.
Und dazu wurde aber auch klar, dass in den letzten Jahren in den Mitgliedstaaten
es relativ viele Gesetze gab, die versucht haben,
irgendwie damit umzugehen, dass diese Online-Plattformen so wahnsinnig viel
Macht entfaltet haben und auch so viel Einfluss haben auf Grundrecht,
wie zum Beispiel Meinungsfreiheit.
Also zum Beispiel das Netz-DG, es gab ein ähnliches Gesetz in Frankreich,
es gab ein ähnliches Gesetz in Österreich, in Dänemark und die waren alle,
sag ich jetzt mal, nicht ideal.
Da gab es natürlich wahnsinnig viel Kritik dran aus verschiedenen Perspektiven,
aber es war klar, hier muss was passieren und es wäre besser,
wenn es auf europäischer Ebene passiert und harmonisiert wird,
als wenn die Mitgliedstaaten sich da so selber ihre Suppe kochen.
Und das war eigentlich die Hauptmotivation für den DSA, dass da mal was passieren
muss und dass Kraut und Rüben auf Mitgliedstaatenebene aufhören muss.
Genau. Und das ist dann letztendlich im DSA gemündet, der würde ich sagen aus vier Teilen besteht.
Der erste Teil sind eben diese grundlegenden Haftungsregeln, also zu Regeln.
Wann ist zum Beispiel eine Plattform, auf der man als Nutzerin Inhalte posten kann?
Wann ist die verantwortlich für meine Inhalte, die vielleicht illegal sind oder
auch nicht? Das ist sozusagen das eine.
Der zweite Teil sind grundlegende Sorgfaltspflichten, die alle erfüllen müssen.
Das heißt zum Beispiel, dass Online-Plattformen oder Hosting-Anbieter Notice-and-Action-Verfahren
anbieten müssen. Das heißt, dass ich als Nutzerin melden kann,
Entschuldigung, hier meine Rechte wurden beschnitten und ich möchte, dass das passiert.
Aber auch grundlegende Transparenzvorschriften zum Beispiel.
Der dritte Teil, und das geht wir ein bisschen zu diesem gestaffelten Ansatz
zurück, beschreibt nochmal besondere Pflichten für die allergrößten Plattformen,
die die meiste Macht haben.
Das heißt, da gibt es dann nochmal Regeln, die darauf eingehen,
dass viele der großen, der sehr großen Plattformen erheblichen Einfluss auf
unsere Gesellschaft haben, auf unser Zusammenleben, auf verschiedene demokratische
Prozesse, aber eben auch Grundrechte, Wahlen etc.
Und dass sich daraus systemische Risiken ergeben können aus dieser Macht.
Das heißt, das sind nochmal besondere Regeln, um mit diesen systemischen Risiken umzugehen.
Und der vierte Teil ist dann sozusagen die Durchsetzung, die Aufsicht,
sozusagen das, ich sag mal, das bürokratische Kleingedruckte,
das natürlich da auch drin stehen muss, was super wichtig ist,
aber das sind so die vier Blöcke des DSA.
Aus meiner Perspektive ist es im Großen und Ganzen gut gelungen.
Ich habe ein paar Kritiken, was einige der Artikel angeht, also sozusagen auch
einige der Ermächtigungen, die sich auch die Europäische Kommission gegeben
hat, was die Aufsicht angeht.
Insbesondere in Krisensituationen, es gibt so einen Krisenmechanismus,
wo die Europäische Kommission dann recht stark eingreifen kann, wo ich denke,
es ist klar, dass es sozusagen unter dem Eindruck des Kriegs in Ukraine,
dieser Krisenmechanismus geschaffen wurde, auch sozusagen unter dem Eindruck
der Erfahrungen in der Corona-Pandemie.
Aber ich denke, da gibt es auf jeden Fall viel Missbrauchspotenzial.
Andere Sache, die sehr problematisch ist, kennen wir auch schon aus dem Netz,
die geht es um eine Verpflichtung von Online-Plattformen, NutzerInnen Daten
und Inhalte proaktiv an Strafverfolgungsbehörden auszuleiten,
wenn sie der Meinung sind, dass sie illegal sind,
beziehungsweise bestimmte Straftaten, also schlimme Straftaten erfüllen könnten.
Leider ist überhaupt nicht definiert, um was wir straftaten.
Das sind so Elemente, wo ich sagen würde, dass der DSA missbraucht werden kann
und eher auch zum Teil in so Überwachungsgesetzgebung geht.
Aber der Großteil, also vor allem die Nutzerinrechte und dieser Ansatz auf systemische
Risiken einzugehen, das halte ich für sehr gelungen.
Aber jetzt müssen wir natürlich ausprobieren, ob es eigentlich funktioniert in der Praxis.
Jetzt hast du schon so mehrfach die Kommission irgendwie immer fallen gelassen,
als irgendwie anscheinend ja...
Persona, die da irgendwie eine Rolle spielt in der Umsetzung von diesem Gesetz.
Wir haben jetzt gerade schon mal kurz über die nationale Ebene gesprochen,
können wir wahrscheinlich später nochmal mehr drüber sprechen,
wie es in Deutschland jetzt eigentlich aussieht und wer da jetzt eigentlich
alles daran beteiligt ist.
Aber ganz grundsätzlich, welche Rolle spielt die EU-Kommission in der Umsetzung
dann von einem solchen Gesetz und dann halt ja auch ganz speziell im Rahmen vom DSA?
Ja, das ist eigentlich ganz spannend, weil, also vielleicht vorab,
die Kommission ist die Aufsichtsbehörde für die allergrößten Plattformen,
also quasi die, die wirklich unser Leben am meisten bestimmen.
Das war aber gar nicht so vorgesehen.
Ursprünglich war es eigentlich so vorgesehen, dass die Mitgliedstaaten,
in denen diese Plattformen gemeldet sind, dass die doch bitte die Aufsicht machen können.
So ein bisschen wie auch bei Datenschutz, Grundverordnung, bei DSGVO.
Wie wir alle wissen, sind die meisten der Plattformen in Irland gemeldet.
Und es gab dann so eine Bewegung, wo klar wurde, so Moment mal,
das war vielleicht nicht die beste Idee im Kontext der DSGVO.
Irland ist nicht so wahnsinnig viel tätig geworden, im Gegenteil.
Das war aber die Untertreibung des Jahrzehnts.
Versuche höflich zu sein. Genau, absolut. Das sollten wir schon mal benennen.
Also die Ehrengelten, also absolute Nulpen in ihren Aufsichtsbehörden.
Das muss man, glaube ich, Leuten, die das nicht wissen, auch so deutlich sagen.
Ja, vielleicht nochmal einen weiteren Schritt zurück.
Also die DSGVO ist die Datenschutzgrundverordnung, die vor, ich glaube mittlerweile
sind es sieben Jahre oder sechs Jahre, sie sind jetzt auf jeden Fall am Review-Prozess.
Also vor fünf, ich glaube fünf Jahre waren es letztes Jahr, in Kraft getreten
sind. 2018 ist sie, meine ich, in Kraft getreten.
Und die ist nämlich so wie du sagst, regelt die Aufsichtsbehörden für die Unternehmen,
für die Aufsichtsbehörden des Landes, in denen die Unternehmen gemeldet sind, hätte ich fast gesagt.
In ihren Sitz haben, sind dafür verantwortlich, die Datenschutzsachen zu entforcen.
Und man sieht immer wieder schön an den Klagen von Neub und Max Schrems,
wie das einfach überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Und anscheinend wurde daraus gelernt, ganz offensichtlich.
Und die DSA-Geschichte, die DSA-Umsetzungsidee scheint ja jetzt irgendwie daran
anzudocken. Genau, das ist der Versuch.
Also es war klar, was bei DSGO-Papiers passiert war, war kompletter Mist.
Das will man auf keinen Fall wiederholen. Es ist aber auch klar,
dass wahrscheinlich die allerbeste Idee ist, wenn jetzt alle 27 damit anfangen,
die größten Plattformen, die in allen diesen Märkten unterwegs sind,
selber zu beaufsichtigen.
Deswegen war so ein bisschen die Idee, wir geben das der Kommission.
Ja, was auf jeden Fall eine spannende neue Rolle ist, mit der die Kommission
glaube ich auch nicht gerechnet hat.
Und vielleicht kannst du noch mal ganz kurz sagen, was die Kommission als Institution
eigentlich ist und warum das vielleicht eine gute Idee ist, alle Länder nicht
das alleine machen zu lassen, sondern die Kommission.
Ja, das ist wirklich eine spannende Frage. Die Kommission beschreibt sich selbst
als die Hüterin der Verträge,
als sozusagen eine angeblich objektive Exekutive, die Gesetzesvorschläge macht
und sie dann auch sozusagen beaufsichtigt immer mal wieder oder umsetzt zum Teil.
Ich würde sagen, die Kommission ist eine zutiefst politische Institution,
weit weg davon objektiv zu sein, sehr stark beeindruckt und beeinflusst von
der Meinung der größten Mitgliedsstaaten insbesondere, nämlich Frankreich und Deutschland.
Und ja, die Hoffnung war, dass die Kommission in der Lage sein wird,
hier die nötige Expertise aufzubauen, Expertise auch zu bündeln und quasi durchschlagskräftiger
ist als nationale Aufsichtsbehörden.
Genau, und vielleicht nochmal so zur Erinnerung, in der Kommission sind aber
alle 27 EU-Staaten durch eine Kommissarin oder einen Kommissar entsprechend
vertreten und deswegen war es wahrscheinlich naheliegend zu sagen,
okay, wenn wir das für den Gesamtmarkt EU machen wollen und wir alle darin vertreten
sein wollen, dann lassen wir die Kommission das doch machen.
Was man jetzt glaube ich ein bisschen bemerkt hat, wenn du darüber erzählst,
ist, dass du mit einer großen Leichtigkeit diese Institutionen überblickst.
Und wir haben eingangs sozusagen von deinem Video noch nicht so sehr viel erzählt.
Also es gibt ja einen Grund, warum du gerade diese EU-Prozesse so gut überblickst.
Erzähl mal ein bisschen, wie du oder was du mit der EU-Kommission zu tun hast
und wie du sozusagen am Ende in diesem Themenfeld ineinander bist.
Also leg mal ein bisschen offen, woher dein tiefes Wissen darüber kommt.
Ja, ich habe da mal gearbeitet.
Also ich habe bei Didi Connect gearbeitet. Das ist quasi der Teil der Kommission,
der für Digitalpolitik verantwortlich ist. Der macht jetzt auch die Aufsicht für den DSA.
Und ich habe da in einem Team gearbeitet, das die Gesetzgebungsprozesse managt.
Das heißt, ich war dafür verantwortlich, sozusagen dafür zu sorgen,
dass Gesetzgebungsprozesse gut laufen, flüssig laufen und Dinge durch diesen
Prozess, diesen co-legislativen Prozess durchgehen.
Was natürlich ein sehr politischer Job quasi ist, dafür zu sorgen,
dass das Ziel der Kommission, die natürlich offiziell gar kein Ziel hat in diesen Verhandlungen,
es ist ja offiziell sind ja Parlament und Rat die Co-Gesetzgeber,
aber die Kommission ist ja im Triolog im Gespräch zu dritt dann ja doch am Tisch
und hat da sehr viele Meinungen.
Das heißt, die Kommission hat bestimmte Ziele, die sie verfolgt mit ihren Gesetzesvorhaben
und die sollten möglichst gut natürlich durch diesen Gesetzesprozess durchkommen,
aber natürlich gibt es auch noch die Rolle, dass die Kommission den anderen
beiden Institutionen unterstützt, Expertise zur Verfügung steht.
Beziehungsweise… Koordiniert, kann man sagen, also auch logistisch.
Koordiniert, genau. Zum Teil auch das, ja.
Genau, das habe ich knapp eineinhalb Jahre gemacht und habe dann Brüssel verlassen,
um mal zu studieren und bin danach über ein Fellowship-Programm,
hatte ich die Möglichkeit, kurz im deutschen Arbeitsministerium zu arbeiten,
aber dann vor allem bei der Electronic Frontier Foundation,
also einer amerikanischen NGO, die sich sehr viel im Bereich, ähm, der
Digitale Rechte einsetzt, die eine sehr andere Perspektive vertritt,
eine sehr tech-kritische Perspektive. Und dann war das Fellowship vorbei.
Ich hatte keinen Job und es war Corona und ich brauchte einen Job.
Und dann hat sich die Möglichkeit ergeben, zu Google zu gehen,
ins Public Policy Team in Deutschland. stand, wo ich durchaus gezögert habe,
aber sehr neugierig war auf die Perspektive von innen, innerhalb einer Plattform.
Ich wollte quasi wissen, wie da eigentlich tatsächlich mit Content Moderation,
Inhalt der Moderation, was so mein Thema war, was ich in den letzten Jahren
davor herausgearbeitet hatte, wie damit umgegangen wird.
Genau und da war ich dann ungefähr drei Jahre und habe sehr,
sehr viel auch am DSA und an ähnlichen Themen gearbeitet und wollte dann zurück
in die Zivilgesellschaft und bin dann so bei der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte gelandet.
Das ist ja ein bisschen selten, glaube ich, dass jemand quasi diese drei Perspektiven hat.
Die EU-Kommission selbst und zwar auch von innen.
Dann ein klassisches, auch sehr stark im Lobbying tätiges Unternehmen, auch von innen.
Und dann die Zivilgesellschaft gleich noch von zwei Perspektiven.
Das ist natürlich eine Expertise, die schon ziemlich selten ist.
Ich glaube, da kommen wir nachher nochmal ein bisschen zurück,
wenn man über diese Durchsetzung und wie die Zusammenarbeit bei uns eigentlich funktionieren soll.
Aber das ist natürlich eine interessante Perspektive. Aber ich muss noch eine andere Frage stellen.
Ja, das ist jetzt mehrfach erwähnt worden. Es gibt also diese Trennung zwischen
sehr, sehr großen Online-Plattformen und die, die mit den Ländern zu tun haben
oder vielleicht ansässig sind mit den Ländern oder zumindest ein Sitz haben mit den Ländern.
Ich glaube, darüber gibt es in der Öffentlichkeit sehr wenig Wissen. Welche sind das?
Wie viele sind das eigentlich? Und wie sind sie definiert?
Das heißt, wie rutscht jemand in diese sehr kleine Gruppe von very large Online-Plattformen,
also sehr große, und wie fällt man wieder raus und wie unterscheiden sich die
Pflichten? Ich glaube, das müssen wir einfach mal sagen. Es geht ja nicht nur um die Aufsicht.
Die die EU-Kommission dann eben zusammen mit anderen machen will,
sondern es geht ja auch darum, wer rutscht da eigentlich rein, wer ist in der Tat.
Ja, also sehr große Online-Plattformen oder sehr große Suchmaschinen,
die gehören nämlich auch dazu, sind Online-Plattformen, die mehr als 45 Millionen
Nutzer in der Europäischen Union haben.
Also das ist schon eine große Schwelle, die überschreitet man nicht so zufällig.
Das sind inzwischen, glaube ich, knapp über 20.
Also ich kann mal kurz durchgehen, es sind, weil sozusagen auch bei manchen
Unternehmen verschiedene Produkte drunter fallen. Also zum Beispiel bei Google
fallen YouTube, aber auch der Playstore, aber auch Google Maps,
Google Shopping drunter.
Das zählt dann quasi als verschiedene.
Ich glaube es sind 13, wenn man die Konzerne zählt. Das kann sein.
Dann zum Beispiel die Meta-Plattformen, also Instagram und Facebook,
es ist Twitter, es ist TikTok, es ist aber auch zum Beispiel Online-Marktplätze,
über die reden wir selten, aber Online-Marktplätze sind auch reguliert vom DSA,
also Amazon, Alibaba, Sheen und Temo wurden auch gerade benannt.
Recht neu sind auch die großen Porno-Plattformen darunter, also X-Hamster und andere.
Da kommen wir schon auf mehr, auf 13, wenn die Pornoplattformen dabei sind.
Genau, dann noch die Suchmaschinen, also die Google-Suche und Bing.
LinkedIn fällt auch drunter, was auch zu Microsoft gehört.
Genau, also sind dann doch recht verschieden. Aber was ist mit diesem komischen
Unternehmen OpenAI Chat GPT, die sich ja mit 90 Millionen Usern brüsten?
Haben die die schon in der EU? Sind die schon dabei?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich eine ganz spannende Frage, weil nicht ganz klar ist,
was die eigentlich für eine Form von Dienst sind.
Ist es ein Hosting-Anbieter? Ist es eine Online-Plattform?
Ist es eine Suchmaschine? Da ist es wahrscheinlich persönlich beleidigt,
wenn man das behaupten würde.
Genau, das ist tatsächlich nicht so ganz klar. Und zum Beispiel auch innerhalb von Suchmaschinen.
Also Suchmaschinen bestehen ja auch aus verschiedenen Produkten.
Es gibt so die zehn blauen Links, so die Klassiker, aber dann auch die vertikalen Integrationen.
Und da ist auch zum Teil nicht ganz klar, welche Regeln für die verschiedenen Teile gelten.
Also da wird es, glaube ich, auch noch Rechtsprechung brauchen,
bis es so völlig klar ist. Aber das sind so die Unternehmen, die darunter fallen.
Okay, und jetzt wissen wir sozusagen auch für diejenigen, die jetzt selber mal Nutzer sind.
Welche sind das? Und dann müssen wir vielleicht noch darüber reden,
wir hatten jetzt die EU-Kommission.
Wir sind ja noch nicht fertig mit der EU-Kommission. Das wäre jetzt mein Punkt, um wieder einzuhaken.
Also das ist sozusagen wahrscheinlich so die Idee, wie es dazu gekommen ist,
dass die EU-Kommission das übernimmt.
Aber was muss die EU-Kommission jetzt eigentlich leisten und macht sie auch
was oder redet sie nur viel darüber gerade?
Ja, also die EU-Kommission hatte die Verpflichtung oder die Aufgabe,
die zu beaufsichtigen, dass diese großen Unternehmen, wo wir schon gemerkt haben,
es sind doch mehr vielleicht als man denkt, dass die den DSA richtig durchsetzen.
Dafür hat es eine ganze Reihe von Möglichkeiten und so Werkzeugen,
die zur Verfügung stehen.
Zum Beispiel müssen die Unternehmen bestimmte Berichte abliefern,
wie sie zum Beispiel mit systemischen Risiken umgegangen sind, wie sie die bekämpfen.
Das heißt, die Kommission hat schon mal eine bessere Informationslage.
Theoretisch. Theoretisch. Ich glaube auch Praxis praktisch. Sie können darüber
hinaus auch nochmal Informationen anfragen, aber es geht sogar so weit,
dass sie Durchsuchungen durchführen könnten oder sozusagen nochmal spezifische
Informationen anfragen können, sicherstellen können.
Das heißt, sie haben relativ große Investigation-Powers, sage ich jetzt mal.
Und die Kommission ist auch sehr schnell sehr aktiv geworden.
Man könnte vielleicht auch sagen, aktivistisch unterwegs gewesen in den ersten
Monaten, also es ging sehr schnell los.
Nicht alles davon wurde auch sehr positiv gesehen, zum Beispiel im Kontext des 7. Oktober.
Gab es dann Briefe des zuständigen Kommissars Thierry Breton,
einem Franzosen, die er dann über Twitter verteilt hat, sozusagen so kommuniziert
hat, an die großen Plattformen, sozusagen mit der Aufforderung,
hier den DSA durchzusetzen und hat da aber auf eine relativ,
wie ich finde, problematische Art und Weise vermischt, um was es eigentlich geht.
Geht es um illegale Inhalte, geht es um Desinformation, was genau sind eigentlich die Pflichten?
Also das war zum Beispiel ein Beispiel recht früh, wo man das Gefühl hatte,
dass hier auch politisch Einfluss genommen wird.
Abgesehen davon hat die Kommission vielleicht noch drei große Prioritäten festgelegt jetzt erstmal.
Also einmal das Thema illegale Inhalte, wie gehen die Plattformen mit illegalen
Inhalten um, also was sind die Meldewege, wie gut funktionieren die Transparenz etc.
Der zweite Bereich ist Kinder- und Jugendschutz, das ist ein weiteres Thema,
das die Kommission sehr wichtig ist. und der dritte natürlich dieses Jahr Wahlen
und sozusagen alles, was mit Integrität von Wahlen zu tun hat, Desinformation etc.
Du hast ja vorhin gesagt, Thierry Breton ist eigentlich dafür zuständig,
aber wie kann man sich das denn vorstellen?
Also eigentlich würde man ja denken, die Kommission, hast du ja eben auch erzählt,
hat eigentlich andere Dinge zu tun, als sich jetzt um Forst mit Aufgaben zu befassen.
Die stellen ja dann wahrscheinlich ein neues Team oder eine neue Abteilung oder
so zusammen, die dann auch wahrscheinlich unpolitisch beständig ist,
ist im Gegensatz zu den Kommissarinnen, die ja jetzt auch nach den Wahlen wechseln werden, oder?
Genau. Also innerhalb von DigiConnect wurde eine Abteilung eigentlich umstrukturiert und umgebaut.
Das ist die Abteilung, in der auch das Team sitzt, das in DSA geschrieben und
verhandelt hat. Da ist sehr, sehr viel Expertise da, generell im Bereich Online-Plattformen.
Und die haben jetzt schon recht viele Leute eingestellt. Ich glaube, es sind inzwischen...
Ja, vielleicht zwischen 70 und 100 Leute, die da im DSA-Konzern zusammenarbeiten,
sind auch gerade noch Stellen offen.
Also die Kommission hat auch recht lange gebraucht, um diese Stellen zu füllen
und tatsächlich auch sozusagen das Team aufzubauen. Das war nicht so leicht für sie.
Aber genau, das sind jetzt quasi verschiedene Teams mit verschiedenen Schwerpunkten,
die aber zusammenarbeiten und soweit ich das verstehe, auf der einen Seite sozusagen
fokussiert sind auf bestimmte Aspekte des DSA,
zum Beispiel Transparenz oder systemische Risiken, auf der anderen Seite aber
auch an bestimmten Untersuchungen arbeiten.
Also, weil das gehört auch dazu, die Kommission hat schon einige Untersuchungen jetzt losgetreten.
Also es gibt zum Beispiel Untersuchungen in Meta, Twitter beziehungsweise X
hat die Kommission auch eine Untersuchung gestartet.
Ich glaube auch, ich muss mal gucken, aber es ist inzwischen eine ganze Reihe,
ich glaube über zehn Untersuchungen, die inzwischen quasi schon losgetreten
worden sind. Zum Teil sind es dann auch nur Nachfragen, wo mehr Informationen gewollt wird.
Zum Beispiel als wir im Februar eine Beschwerde gegenüber LinkedIn eingereicht
haben, hat die Europäische Kommission dann als ersten Schritt erstmal LinkedIn
nach mehr Informationen gefragt.
Das ist aber sozusagen auch eine Enforcement-Action, die von diesem Team kam.
Und die könnten ja auch nichts tun. Genau, sie können auch nicht so.
Der Europäischen Kommission. Theoretisch müssten,
Wir uns alle an unsere nationalen Aufsichtsbehörde nennen, der Digital Services
Coordinator, beziehungsweise auf Deutsch die Koordinierungsstelle.
Und da kann man dann quasi Beschwerden einreichen, wozu man möchte.
Und wenn es sich dabei um sehr große Online-Plattformen handelt,
dann hat quasi diese nationale Aufsichtsbehörde die Verpflichtung,
das an die Kommission weiterzugeben.
Da es ja in Deutschland bis vor kurzem noch keine Behörde gab,
haben wir dann eben zum Beispiel das direkt bei der Kommission eingereicht,
auch wenn es keinen offiziellen Weg dafür gab. Was in dem Fall gut funktioniert
hat, aber natürlich auch mit dem Problem einhergeht, dass wir keinerlei prozessuale Rechte hatten.
Also die Kommission, genau wie gesagt, die hätten nichts machen müssen,
die hätten sich einfach nie wieder über uns melden können und wir hätten keine
rechtlichen Wege gehabt, dagegen vorzugehen.
Ist das denn jetzt anders? Es gibt jetzt sozusagen diesen Coordinator,
das ist in Deutschland die Bundesnetzagentur, das ist auch gesetzlich geregelt. Genau.
Müsst ihr euch mit denen dann jetzt ins Benehmen setzen oder wendet ihr euch
dann direkt in die Bundesnetzagentur? Wie wird es jetzt laufen?
Ja, also wir haben vor zwei Wochen eine weitere Beschwerde eingereicht,
wo wir es mal ausprobieren wollten, wie denn jetzt der Weg eigentlich ist.
Und da haben wir festgestellt, dass es jetzt ein Formular gibt auf der Webseite
der BNetz A, wo man Dinge einreichen kann.
Wir hatten recht umfangreiche Nachweise bzw. Beweise, die wir dann in verschiedenen
ZIP-Files dort hochladen wollten, dann aber leider feststellen mussten,
dass man keine ZIP-Files hochladen kann.
Man kann nur fünf Bilddateien hochladen und hat eine sehr begrenzte Zeichenzahl.
Ja genau, das heißt da kommt schon ein bisschen durch, was sie sich vorstellen
an Beschwerden, wovon sie ausgehen, was sie bekommen und ich glaube die rechnen
vor allem damit sozusagen von einzelnen Personen zu hören, was ihnen auf einer
Plattform widerfahren ist, wo sie ihre Rechte nicht eingehalten wurden.
Aber ich glaube sozusagen, dass wir dort einreichen wollten,
nämlich Beschwerden gegen fünf verschiedene Unternehmen, das war jetzt nicht so vorgesehen.
Das heißt, in dem Fall haben wir dann auch wieder sozusagen dann per E-Mail
bei der BNSA die Beschwerde eingereicht, aber auch parallel an die Europäische
Kommission, weil es eben um sehr große Online-Plattformen ging und das natürlich klar ist,
dass letztendlich sowieso bei der Kommission landet.
Vielleicht können wir ja nochmal in Deutschland bleiben.
Wir haben jetzt schon von dem Koordinator oder Koordinierungsstelle gehört, das ist die BNSA.
Aber wie ist das denn jetzt eigentlich in der Umsetzung in Deutschland vorgesehen?
Wer ist da eigentlich beteiligt oder nicht beteiligt? Und was sind da auch dann
Nutzerinnenrechte, die wir irgendwie einklagen können auf unterschiedlichen Ebenen?
Ja, also vielleicht erstmal ganz kurz, wen beaufsichtigt die deutsche Aufsicht?
Ziemlich viele Unternehmen, also sozusagen Plattformunternehmen,
E-Commerce-Unternehmen, die in Deutschland gemeldet sind, das sind ziemlich viele.
Kannst du mal ein paar Beispiele nennen, weil das ist glaube ich vielleicht
nicht so bekannt. Das größte zum Beispiel Amazon, Zalando.
Zalando ist ein sehr großes Online-Plattform.
Ein deutsches Unternehmen sitzt in Deutschland. Die deutsche Aufsicht ist dafür verantwortlich.
Aber auch so Sachen wie nebenan.de oder eBag Kleinanzeigen.
Soundcloud glaube ich auch.
Also es gibt eine Liste, die als PDF da schon verfügbar ist,
die hat aber glaube ich nur elf oder zwölf Einträge.
Ich denke, die ist erstmal nur vorläufig und wird ganz sicherlich erweitert
werden. Ja, es müssten mehrere tausend Unternehmen sein.
Die ist aber super klein. Also ich habe eben geguckt, also wir sind jetzt Ende
Juni, da ist offenbar noch alles im Aufbau.
Ja, also natürlich auch viele ganz kleine Blogs fallen natürlich theoretisch auch drunter.
Es sind Hosting-Anbieter, die hosten vielleicht Kommentare von ihren NutzerInnen
oder Community-Mitgliedern, die fallen theoretisch auch drunter.
Also es ist wirklich eine sehr, sehr diverse Palette auch.
Genau, also das wird beaufsichtigt. Und wer das tut, ist auch kompliziert.
Also die BNSA koordiniert das, Digital Services Coordinator,
weil auch so viele verschiedene Bereiche involviert sind, dass verschiedene
Behörden involviert sind. Das sind zum Beispiel die Bundesbeauftragte für Datenschutz
in der Informationsgesellschaft, BFDI.
Informationsfreiheit. Informationsfreiheit, genau. BFDI ist beteiligt für die
Artikel im DSA, wo es konkret um Datenschutz geht.
Dann gibt es aber auch Artikel, die sich konkret um Kinder- und Jugendmedienschutz drehen.
Das heißt, dass dann sowohl die BZKJ, also die Bundeszentrale für Kinder- und
Jugendmedienschutz, als auch die Landesmedienanstalten, die sich das Thema Aufsicht
im Bereich Kinder- und Jugendmedienschutz mit der BZKJ teilen,
Ein klassisches föderales Thema.
Die sind auch beteiligt. Dann, weil wir ja gerade schon gesagt haben,
auch Marktplätze sind beteiligt.
Auf Marktplätzen werden potenziell Dinge gehandelt, Produkte gehandelt, die illegal sind.
Das heißt auch Produktsicherheitsbehörden, Verbraucherschutz sozusagen auch drin beteiligt.
Ich vergesse bestimmt gerade irgendjemanden, aber das sind so die großen Kategorien.
Das heißt, es sind sehr, sehr viele Behörden daran beteiligt und die BNZ A hat
vor allem die Aufgabe, das zu koordinieren und dann quasi auch Beschwerden oder
auch Untersuchungen an die Behörde weiterzugeben, die am ehesten dafür zuständig
ist und dafür kompetent ist.
Man sieht ja schon, es ist im Aufbau.
Du hast jetzt so Zahlen genannt, es werden wahrscheinlich tausend Unternehmen
sein, aber ob es da eine Gesamtliste der Ansprechpartner geben wird, weiß man nicht.
Aber betonen tut ja die Beschwerdestelle sofort, wenn man da hinklickt,
dass es eigentlich nicht um so individuelle Dinge geht,
also dass die Nutzer nicht hinkommen sollen und sagen, mein Account wurde gesperrt,
sondern dass sie auf systematische oder regelmäßige Verstöße hingewiesen werden
wollen mit ihrem Beschwerdeformular. Ähm...
Also Khaleesi hat eben so ein bisschen nach den Rechten der Nutzer eigentlich
gefragt und da müsste ich ja eher an Vereine denken,
die sowas machen können, um regelverstöße oder systematische Regelverstöße aufzudenken
und nicht an den Einzelnen, der sich vielleicht mal falsch behandelt fühlt oder
keine Meldestelle findet.
Also das ist ja eigentlich so ein Konstrukt, der nicht sehr freundlich für die
Nutzer ist, oder? Ja, deswegen ist uns unsere Arbeit eben auch so wichtig,
dass wir sie überreichen. Also das ist genau das Problem.
Der DSA sagt auch sehr deutlich, dass einzelne Rechtsverstöße nicht das Problem sind.
Systematische Rechtsverstöße können geahndet werden. Das heißt,
wenn sozusagen Facebook einmal was falsch entscheidet, ist es schon okay.
Damit muss man rechnen bei skalierter Inhaltemoderation.
Es geht sozusagen darum, laufen Dinge systematisch falsch und das ist natürlich
für einzelne NutzerInnen total unbefriedigend, weil die tatsächlich nicht unbedingt
jemand haben, an den sie sich wenden können oder es mit sehr viel Aufwand verbunden
ist. Es gibt natürlich Vereine, NGOs, wie zum Beispiel die GFF, aber auch HateAid.
Es gibt auch andere Beratungsstellen für insbesondere Betroffene von Hass im
Netz und von digitaler Gewalt, die da helfen können.
Aber es ist nicht super offensichtlich, an wie man sich wenden kann.
Es gibt noch Verbraucherschutzzentrale, die sind auch hilfreich,
aber muss man natürlich auch erstmal kennen. Also ich würde auch sagen,
dass die Hürden recht hoch sind.
Es gibt eine, so eine Innovation im DSA ist, dass man sich als Nutzerin auch
vertreten lassen kann von zum Beispiel Vereinen wie der GVF.
Das heißt sozusagen, dein Inhalt wurde entfernt, du willst dagegen vorgehen,
hast aber vielleicht gerade nicht die mentale Bandbreite, dich auch noch darum zu kümmern.
Gerade von Menschen, die systematisch betroffen sind, von zum Beispiel Hass
im Netz, ein riesiges Problem.
Das heißt, man kann sich in die Situation vertreten lassen von jemand anderem,
der dann diese Rechte für dich einfordert.
Aber es ist natürlich auch etwas, was man erstmal wissen muss.
Und ich denke, das ist tatsächlich ein riesiger Fehlstand aktuell,
dass auch die BNSA bis jetzt kaum investiert hat in Aufklärung,
in überhaupt Bekanntmachung, was es in DSA gibt, an auch exakt die Ausstattung
von Vereinen, von Stellen, von Beratungsorganisationen, an die man sich wenden
kann. Also da gibt es, würde ich sagen, eine relativ große Lücke.
Vielleicht sollte man nochmal eine Sache zum Verständnis klar machen.
Ich habe das jetzt ein bisschen kritisch angemerkt, aber erstmal ist ja der
DSA, du hast es vorhin erwähnt, ich werde es nur nochmal betonen, dafür da,
dass die Pflichten für die großen Plattformen besser werden in Bezug zum Beispiel auf die Meldung.
Also die müssen auch nachgewiesen bestimmte Beschwerdewege haben und auch reagieren,
zum Beispiel auch nicht immer nur automatisiert reagieren.
Also im Prinzip ist ja der DSA vor allen Dingen dafür da, dass es diese Wege
überhaupt gibt und zwar überall.
Und mein Plädoyer sollte jetzt nicht unbedingt sein, okay, das müsste jetzt
die Bundesnetzagentur machen.
Aber das Letzte, was du gesagt hast,
ist, glaube ich, jetzt wichtiger klarzumachen, was sagt denn der DSA?
Was kann ich als Einzelner tun?
Und vielleicht auch, wo sind diese Beschwerdestellen bei den großen Plattformen,
das wäre doch eigentlich eine Forderung, die man an die Bundesnetzagentur stellen
könnte, oder siehst du das anders?
Ich glaube, das ist auch wieder so ein Klassiker, dass wir jetzt irgendwie als
Zivilgesellschaft wieder schauen müssen.
Dass sowohl alle Menschen ihre Rechte kennen, die sie jetzt auf einmal innehaben,
aber nicht nur dafür sorgen müssen, dass das passiert, sondern auch noch dafür sorgen müssen,
dass es irgendwie eine Durchsetzung dieser Rechte gibt, oder wie siehst du das?
Ja, genau. Das ist natürlich auf der einen Seite eine Rolle,
die die Zivilgesellschaft auch schon immer hatte, so Watchdog auch sein,
werden eigentlich Dinge umgesetzt und auch wollte.
Also es waren auch ganz klar in den Verhandlungen zum DSA, die europäische Zivilgesellschaft
war sehr stark involviert, hat sehr viel Expertise, kann sehr viel damit dazu beisteuern.
Aber ich würde auch sagen, es gibt da so ein gewisses Spannungsfeld.
Man kann nicht gleichzeitig mit der Kommission zusammenarbeiten und sozusagen
Enforcement anstreben.
Und gleichzeitig die Kommission beaufsichtigen und Watchdog sein.
Das ist so das Spannungsverhältnis. Und dazu kommt die ungeklärte Finanzierungslage
für ganz viele Organisationen.
Also in Deutschland, wir reden jeden Tag hier natürlich alle über die Haushaltsverhandlungen.
Ganz, ganz viele NGOs in dem Bereich sind ganz akut davon betroffen.
Das könnte wirklich massiv in ihre Arbeit einschneiden. und genauso natürlich
auch in anderen Ländern oder auf der europäischen Ebene.
Also es gibt einfach viel zu wenig Geld für diese Arbeit und aktuell würde ich
schon sagen, ist es so, dass es eine Erwartungshaltung gibt von Aufsichtsbehörden,
insbesondere der Kommission, an die Zivilgesellschaft,
hey, ihr wolltet es immer, jetzt ist der DSA da, jetzt liefert doch mal Beweise,
jetzt sagt doch mal, wo läuft es denn schlecht und das ist natürlich auch eine
tolle Aufgabe und das ist auch eine wichtige Aufgabe und wir wollen natürlich
auch da uns beteiligen und da hilfreich sein.
Aber ich würde sagen, es ist eine relativ große Spannung Und ich denke,
aktuell läuft es noch ganz gut und es ist gut angelaufen und die Kommission
ist auch sehr offen und möchte auch diese, also wirklich sehr,
sehr offen und zugewandt, aber es ist natürlich klar, dass früher oder später
da Konflikte auftauchen werden und dann wird es spannend.
Bei der Bundesnetzagentur selbst, also dem deutschen Coordinator,
gibt es auch eine zivilgesellschaftliche Beteiligung.
Die ist in einem Beirat festgelegt, der sich zusammensetzt aus zur Hälfte Zivilgesellschaft,
ein Viertel Wissenschaft und ein Viertel Wirtschaft.
Ist schon was bekannt, wer in diesem Beirat sein wird?
Nee, noch gar nicht. Also der existiert noch gar nicht, ne?
Es gibt auch keine Gerüchte, die du jetzt hier exklusiv in unserem Super-Podcast...
Keiner von uns hat was davon gehört, deswegen kann da ja niemand drin sitzen.
Also soweit ich gehört habe, soll das noch vor dem Sommer passieren.
Nächste Woche ist die letzte Sitzungswoche. Ich weiß nicht genau,
wie Sommer berechnet wird.
Denn der Bundestag muss sozusagen da sein, okay geben. Genau,
also sozusagen der Prozess, das kann ich vielleicht kurz sagen,
der Prozess ist so, weil ich es verstanden habe, aber ist der Ausschuss für
Digitales, also sozusagen Mitglied des Beirats, benennt.
Und ich denke, die werden dann vom Bundestag bestätigt. Ich glaube, das ist das Verfahren.
Also gut, wir können keine exklusiven Informationen über den Beirat raustun, leider.
Das wäre jetzt schön gewesen. Aber ich möchte nochmal betonen,
dass es wirklich, das ist was, also es steht nicht im DSA, es hätte Deutschland
nicht machen müssen. Aber das ist wirklich eine gute Idee.
Also es gibt keine Verpflichtung, Zivilgesellschaft überhaupt zu beteiligen.
Und das zum Beispiel etwas,
was sehr, sehr sinnvoll auch wäre auf europäischer Ebene, um eben auch sozusagen
ein Forum zu schaffen, das existiert, wo Zivilgesellschaft sich beteiligen kann,
wo sie Input geben kann, was aber nicht vom guten Willen der Kommission abhängig
ist, sondern was festgeschrieben ist, was ein Sekretariat hat, was Mittel hat.
Deswegen, das ist eigentlich so meine Hoffnung, dass sich auch andere daran
ein Beispiel nehmen und das so ein bisschen Schule macht.
Naja und ich glaube natürlich auch, gerade bei solchen Content-Moderation-Fragen,
aber auch bei anderen Fragen, die da reguliert werden sollen,
weil es ist natürlich wichtig, lokale Expertise zu haben in einer zentralen Stelle,
was natürlich am besten wahrscheinlich passieren würde über zivilgesellschaftliche
Expertise, die bei der EU-Kommission dann auch nochmal gesammelt ist.
Genau, es gibt quasi ein Board of Coordinators, wo sich quasi 27 Aufsichtsbehörden
der Länder nochmal vereinigen und treffen.
Also doch, hat das mit der Kommission doch nicht so gut geklappt.
Die kommen jetzt doch alle in eine eigene Aufsicht.
Und da denke ich, wäre der richtige Ort, um das anzusiedeln.
Okay, jetzt haben wir ein bisschen über den Ist-Zustand geredet.
Wir haben ein bisschen geredet, welche Institutionen hier was tun.
Vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen in die Kristallkugel geguckt.
Ich würde das gerne mal wissen, wie das beim, jetzt aus Sicht der GFF,
was sozusagen euer Plan ist für die Nahzeit.
Welchen Unternehmen wollt ihr euch widmen?
Wo sind so die Themen, die euch unter den Nägeln brennen? Also wo wollt ihr
da aktiv werden? Du hast schon gesagt, ihr habt jetzt schon mal einmal bei der
EU-Kommission probiert.
Wie reagieren die, wenn ihr euch da strukturell beschwert?
Und auch schon mit der Bundesnetzagentur.
Aber wo sind denn eigentlich die Sachen, die euch unter den Nägeln brennen,
inhaltlich? Also wo glaubt ihr, wo sind die Beschwerden, die man noch echt mal
breittreten muss? Ja, drei Bereiche.
Der erste ist klassisch Inhalte-Moderation, also die Durchsetzung und Wahrung
von Grundrechten in der Inhalte-Moderation.
Da sind wir auch einfach angewiesen darauf, dass Menschen zu uns kommen und
uns erzählen, was ihnen passiert ist.
Also hier der Aufruf, wenn eure Inhalte gesperrt werden oder euer Konto blockiert
wird, dann meldet euch gerne.
Wenn ihr das Gefühl habt, dass es sozusagen nicht rechtsmäßig passiert ist,
dass vielleicht auch bestimmte politische Inhalte zensiert worden sind oder
darauf eingegriffen wurde, dann sind wir erstmal neugierig und schauen uns das gerne an.
Der zweite Bereich ist der Zugang zu Forschungsdaten.
Da haben wir noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen, aber das ist auch eine große
Innovation des DSA, dass es ein relativ weitgehendes neues Recht gibt für Forschende
Zugang zu Plattformdaten zu bekommen.
Das wollen wir durchsetzen mit Forschenden, also wirklich dafür kämpfen,
dass sie Daten auch bekommen.
Wir haben uns natürlich auch vorstellen können, dass wir der Plattform versuchen
werden zu weigern, diese Daten rauszugeben.
Aber auch ganz konkret wollen wir unterstützen, indem wir Konzepte für Datenschutz
und Datensicherheit erarbeiten und zur Verfügung stellen, damit andere das nutzen
können und ihre Chancen überhaupt, einen Antrag zu schreiben,
der durchkommen könnte, um die zu verbessern. Und der dritte.
Plattform Design nenne, also die Aspekte des DSA, die nicht unbedingt auf einzelne
NutzerInnenrechte abzielen, wie zum Beispiel im Bereich der Inhaltemoderation,
sondern eigentlich wirklich das Design und die Gestaltung von Online-Plattformen
angehen, die aber dann sehr, sehr großen Einfluss darauf haben,
wie NutzerInnen sich dort bewegen können und was sie vorfinden.
Also zum Beispiel Transparenzberichterstattung, algorithmische Empfehlungssysteme.
Die Regelung zu Online-Werbung, die systemischen Risiken, das sind Sachen, die uns interessieren.
Und ich denke, da ist noch sehr, sehr viel zu tun.
Also in allen drei Kategorien kann man sehr viel oder muss aus meiner Sicht
sehr viel überprüft werden. Du hast zum Beispiel gerade schon die Meldewege besprochen.
Da gibt es jetzt auch schon erste Beschwerden, aber es ist klar,
dass die Meldewege auf vielen Plattformen nicht besonders gut ausgestattet sind,
auch nicht besonders gut funktionieren, nicht einfach zu nutzen sind.
Ich denke auch bei so ein paar anderen Sachen, es gibt zum Beispiel Verpflichtungen,
NutzerInnen über jede Inhalte-Moderation-Aktion zu benachrichtigen,
auch wenn Inhalte nicht entfernt werden, sondern eingeschränkt,
wenn eine Sichtbarkeit, also Shadowbanning vorliegt, was auch sehr selten passiert,
dass diese Benachrichtigungen verschickt werden.
Also ich denke, da gibt es schon so große systemische Fragen,
an die wir gerne ran möchten.
Du hast jetzt aber vermieden, irgendeine bestimmte große Online-Plattform mal zu benennen.
Also habt ihr hier irgendwelche besonders im Fokus, die euch schon total negativ aufgefallen sind?
Oder ist das jetzt erstmal nur… Was natürlich irgendwie immer in aller Munde
ist, auch gerade wenn wir über Missinformationen reden und du hast es gerade
auch gar nicht genannt, glaube ich, bei den Großen, was ist eigentlich mit TikTok?
Das ist ja immer eine gute Frage.
Inwieweit sind die vom DSA betroffen? Setzen sie den um? Weigern sie sich eher, den umzusetzen?
Was ist da dein Eindruck? Also TikTok ist auch eine sehr große Plattform,
fällt auch darunter. Wir haben auch schon eine Beschwerde, also diese Sammelbeschwerde,
die ich kurz erwähnt habe, da war TikTok auch dabei.
TikTok, aus meiner Erfahrung, so wie ich drauf blicke, bemüht sich, compliant zu sein.
Also ich glaube, TikToks generelle Strategie ist eher, Dinge umzusetzen und
da zum Beispiel dann weniger auch auf das Ausbalancieren von verschiedenen Grundrechten
zu schauen als vielleicht andere.
Also zum Beispiel, gerade wenn es um Datenausleitungen an den Strafverfolgungsbehörden
geht, mein Eindruck ist, TikTok ist eher bereit, Dinge auszuleiten,
ohne nochmal nachzufragen.
Ehrlich gesagt, wir schauen weniger auf konkrete Unternehmen,
aber eher auf konkrete Themen, die uns interessieren.
Also bis jetzt haben wir eigentlich fast alle großen Plattformen,
wo Inhalte geteilt werden, haben wir schon ein bisschen eingereicht.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die ich persönlich besonders spannend finde,
zum Beispiel App-Stores. Ich habe das Gefühl, da passieren wilde Sachen.
Sehr, sehr wenig Transparenz darüber, wie da eigentlich Inhalte moderiert werden.
Online-Werbung ist auch so ein Thema, wo ich das Gefühl habe,
dass relativ wenig Aufmerksamkeit drauf ist.
Vor allem auch Monetarisierung von Inhalten. Also sehr viele Menschen verdienen
relativ viel Geld damit, Inhalte zu produzieren.
Wenn diese Monetarisierung weggenommen wird, ist ein gigantischer Einschnitt,
auch relativ wenig Fokus darauf.
Und gleichzeitig auch das Gefühl, es gibt viele Themen, die sehr,
also von sehr vielen sehr engmaschig betreut werden.
Also zum Beispiel Desinformation ist natürlich so ein Thema,
das auch gerade einfach sehr schick ist, so im Kontext der Wahlen.
Es gibt ganz viele Meinungen dazu.
Ich finde es sehr schwierig, damit umzugehen. Auch die Definition,
die Entscheidung zwischen.
Desinformation, Missinformation, Missverständnissen ist nicht immer so leicht.
Oder zum Beispiel auch Twitter ist ja auch so ein Fall.
Also alle stürzen sich auf Twitter und Und klar, ich finde auch,
das ist skandalös, wie schlecht Dinge dort funktionieren, aber da ist das Gefühl,
das ist gut abgedeckt, da müssen wir jetzt nicht auch noch unsere Kapazitäten drauf verwenden.
Ja, da würde mich eine Einschätzung auch nochmal interessieren,
Konz hat es ja auch gerade gesagt, der DSA war so ein bisschen driven bei die
EU-Wahlen kommen und da müssen wir irgendwas gegen Missinformationen tun und so weiter und so fort.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass der DSA so extrem trend-driven ist in den Sachen,
die er versucht zu regeln oder hast du schon das Gefühl,
dass es auch jetzt in der Umsetzung auch wirklich zu gut überlegten Regelungen kommt?
Also ich würde nicht sagen, dass es von Trends um den geprägt ist,
aber es war schon ein Versuch auf aktuelle Herausforderungen einzugehen.
Und eben manchmal besser, manchmal schlechter. Also ich glaube dieser Krisenmechanismus,
den ich erwähnt habe, ist für mich zum Beispiel von eher nicht so gut gelaufen.
Die Artikel zu systemischen Risiken, wo zum Beispiel auch Desinformation oder
Schutz von Wahlen drin sind, würde ich sagen, die machen schon mehr Sinn.
Also für mich gibt es da so ein grundlegendes Missverständnis.
Also Desinformation ist ja in aller, allermeisten Fällen nicht rechtswidrig.
Also die Inhalte, die da verbreitet werden, sind meistens nicht rechtswidrig.
Es ist scheiße, es ist oft falsch, es sind oft Dinge, die aus dem Kontext gerissen
werden oder falsch in den Kontext gestellt werden, aber es ist selten illegal. Illegal.
Der DSA reguliert in allererster Linie illegale Inhalte.
Das heißt, es ist relativ begrenzt, was man unter dem DSA tun kann,
um gegen Desinformation vorzugehen.
Und das wird manchmal so ein bisschen übertrieben dargestellt,
weil natürlich auch das für die Politik jetzt wichtig ist zu sagen,
nee, wir haben den DSA und den
setzen wir jetzt durch und damit ist Desinformation bekämpft in Europa.
Aber es ist ja ein sehr viel komplexeres Problem mit sehr vielen verschiedenen
komplexen Akteuren, die daran beteiligt sind und einfach nur zu sagen,
Plattformen sollen jetzt mehr Desinformation löschen, wird dem überhaupt nicht gerecht.
Deswegen bin ich da so ein bisschen skeptisch und ich glaube,
das ist auch wichtig, nicht den DSA zu überladen mit Erwartungen,
die er nicht erfüllen kann. Ich glaube, das sehen wir jetzt auch schon so.
Niemand weiß, wie gut die DSA-Compliance aussieht. Das wissen wir nicht,
das wissen die Unternehmen nicht, das weiß aber auch die Europäische Kommission nicht.
Das ist so ein bisschen auch so ein iterativer Prozess. Manche Sachen sind natürlich
total offensichtlich, dass es einfach schlecht läuft und wir wissen ziemlich
genau, wie es gut aussehen könnte. Bei vielen Dingen, gerade so Sachen wie,
was ist denn ein systemisches Risiko für den öffentlichen Diskurs und wie gehst
du dagegen vor als Plattform?
Das ist nicht, was ich jetzt zwei Sätzen beantworten könnte.
Ich glaube, ich habe ein paar Ideen, aber es ist nicht ganz klar,
wie ideale Compliance damit aussieht. Das heißt, ich glaube,
wir müssen auch feuchtig sein, gerade in den ersten Monaten,
vielleicht auch im ersten Jahr zu sagen, Dinge funktionieren nicht,
der DSA muss nachgeschafft werden.
Wir müssen auch erstmal Erfahrungen damit sammeln und herausfinden,
was wir eigentlich machen können, was gut funktioniert, was schlecht funktioniert
und auch so ein bisschen, glaube ich, gemeinsam.
Uns zu dieser Herausforderung stellen, dass wir noch nicht alle Antworten haben.
Vielleicht apropos komplexe Probleme und Dinge ausprobieren.
Ich habe ja ganz am Anfang über die Chatkontrolle geredet und ich sage häufig
gerne auch mal zu PolitikerInnen, dass sie erstmal abwarten sollen,
was der DSA eigentlich für Kinder- und Jugendschutz tun kann und welche Maßnahmen
wir da entwickeln können. Wie blickst du denn da drauf?
Sagst du so, ja, da gibt es schon gute Tools, wo man jetzt erstmal schauen muss, was passiert?
Oder hast du eher so das Gefühl, das ist wieder so eine Erwartungshaltung an
den DSA, die er gar nicht erfüllen kann?
Also DSA sagt zum Kinder- und Jugendschutz auf der einen Seite,
dass sozusagen Plattformen sich Dinge ausdenken müssen, um Kinder und Jugendliche zu schützen.
Und dass sie das quasi auch wirklich auf systemischer Ebene einbauen müssen
und dass sie auch das sozusagen überprüfen und bewerten müssen.
Und da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Also diese Risikoberichte werden irgendwann
im Laufe des Jahres veröffentlicht werden und ich glaube, damit kann man was machen.
Wovor ich so ein bisschen Sorge habe, ist, dass auch im Kontext des DSA diskutiert
wird, ob Altersverifizierung nicht eigentlich ein notwendiges Tool ist,
Werkzeug ist, um den DSA umzusetzen und um Kinder und Jugendliche zu schützen.
Und da habe ich große Bedenken, wie wir alle natürlich.
Aber das ist so, da habe ich Sorge, dass quasi in irgendwelchen Arbeitsgruppen
weit weg von der Öffentlichkeit und von demokratischen Gesetzgebungsprozessen
dann die Altersverifizierung so
über die Hintertür durch den DSA dann vielleicht doch noch Schule macht.
Und da sehe ich auf jeden Fall eine große Gefahr.
Ja, und ich glaube, das ist auch ein viel unterschätztes Thema.
Alle reden da manchmal im Zusammenhang mit der Chatkontrolle drüber,
vergessen das aber auch sehr schnell, dass das in der Chatkontrolle vorgesehen ist.
Und ich glaube, man sollte auch im Hinterkopf haben, dass es nicht nur ein Thema
ist, was die Chatkontrolle sich vorstellt oder im Rahmen des DSA kommen könnte,
weil sie jetzt da doch drauf rumreiten, auch in Deutschland.
Sondern dass auch viele Landesmedienanstalten das gerne im Jugendmedienschutzgesetz
sehen würden. Also ich glaube, das ist was,
Wo wir noch viel mit zu tun haben werden. Ich glaube, wir werden dazu mal was
schreiben, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Jetzt live on tape.
Aber ich glaube, das ist etwas, was man immer im Hinterkopf behalten sollte.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, wie du sagst, die Plattformen sollen Dinge einbauen.
Die sollen irgendwie auch schauen, was funktioniert und das auch entsprechend reporten.
Und da habe ich irgendwie doch nochmal die Hoffnung, dass wir so ein bisschen
evidenzbasiert mal sehen, wie die Sachen tatsächlich aussehen könnten,
ohne dass wir totale Kontrolle ausüben müssen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du gerade den Kopf geschüttelt hast oder genickt hast.
Ja, ich habe die Hoffnung auch, mal sehen. Also ich finde interessant zu sehen,
dass du relativ entspannt rangehst und auch so ein bisschen mit einer gewissen
Neugierde für die neuen Mechanismen,
zu sehen, wie wird das laufen, was wir noch nie ausprobiert haben.
Das finde ich eigentlich einen ganz guten Ansatz. Ich muss aber auf etwas zurückkommen,
weil du zweimal explizit auch als Schwäche des DSA diesen Krisenmechanismus erwähnt hast.
Und ich denke, wir schulden den Hörern auf jeden Fall die Erklärung.
Was ist dieser Krisenmechanismus und wo siehst du die große Gefahr?
Ich sehe die nämlich auch.
Ich finde, die ist total underreported, also wird zu wenig darüber gesprochen.
Deswegen sollten wir das mal aufklären, oder? Ja, also kurz zusammengefasst
sagt der Krisenmechanismus, dass es in Fällen von Krisen, und die sind weit
definiert, öffentliche Sicherheit,
Public Health, Corona-Pandemie.
Also meine nationale Sicherheit. Nationaler Sicherheit, genau.
Kann die Kommission den Plattformen Maßnahmen vorschreiben, beziehungsweise
ihnen vorschlagen, dass sie dazu zwingen, Maßnahmen zu ergreifen.
Und das ist ziemlich offen alles. Also ich sage das jetzt auch so ein bisschen
erlaubt, weil auch dieser Artikel sehr, sehr offen ist. Also es lässt viel zu.
Und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wenn wir zum Beispiel zurückdenken an die
Corona-Pandemie, da war es ja auch, sage ich mal, sehr dynamische Diskussion.
So verbreiten Online-Plattformen eigentlich gerade lebensrettende Informationen
oder eigentlich nur Desinformationen? Und da hat es ja die Einschätzung,
was eigentlich Desinformation ist oder nicht, täglich eigentlich geändert.
Und da sozusagen an so einem zentralen Punkt eine so politische Institution
zu haben, die da direkt eingreifen kann, das halte ich für sehr gefährlich.
Ich erinnere daran, dass mit Beginn des Ukraine-Konfliktes wir einfach ja auch
ganz drastische Zensurmast haben, die ich, glaube ich, seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
nicht mehr gesehen habe in Europa, durchgesetzt haben, die bis heute bestehen
in Bezug auf russische Sender.
Und ich denke mal, da könnte uns noch einige drohen. Aber das hast du doch eben wieder gemacht.
Du hast jetzt explizit die Desinformation erwähnt, aber eigentlich geht es ja
um rechtswidrige Inhalte, nicht wahr?
Also die Diskussion darum ist doch echt oft entkoppelt von dem, was da drinsteht.
Ja, ich glaube, es wird auch oft verkürzt. Also vielleicht habe ich auch gerade
ein bisschen zu sehr verkürzt.
Kann ja auch sozusagen sein, dass dann in so einer Krise es dann eher darum
geht, dass vielleicht nochmal genauer geschaut wird, wie man nicht vielleicht
doch auch manche Sachen als illegal sozusagen herdefinieren kann.
Oder eben, dass bestimmte Maßnahmen ergriffen werden müssen,
um bestimmte Inhalte, Kategorien einzugrenzen oder Informationen bereitzustellen.
Aber auch das, also wenn sozusagen staatliche Akteure einen direkten Weg haben,
also Unternehmen mit gigantischem Reach dazu zu zwingen, bestimmte Informationen
bereitzustellen, das finde ich auch potenziell problematisch.
Also sozusagen die andere Seite, ja. Genau, die andere Seite.
Ja, ich glaube, das sind so Sachen, die, ja, wir müssen einfach warten,
was passiert. Also ich sehe sozusagen alle Missbrauchsoptionen recht deutlich.
Gleichzeitig ist glaube ich auch klar, dass da viel Aufmerksamkeit drauf ist,
dass da auch die Gesellschaft sehr wachsam ist.
Von daher, ich glaube, ja, ich würde nicht sagen, wir müssen auf die nächste
Krise warten und schauen, was passiert.
Aber ich glaube, es ist vielen klar, dass dieser Mechanismus nicht ideal ist
und dass es da viele Fragezeichen gibt und dass da auch die Kommission mit sehr,
sehr viel Sorgfalt agieren werden muss.
Okay, also vielleicht so als Abschluss jetzt, wir haben jetzt nochmal über diesen
Krisenmechanismus gesprochen, was würdest du denn, was sind so Facts,
die man mitnehmen sollte über den DSA, die vielleicht nicht so klar sind?
Also du hast schon ein paar genannt jetzt während unseres Gesprächs,
aber so vielleicht ganz abschließend, dass das nochmal das ist,
was man jetzt aus dieser Folge mitnimmt.
Was sollte man über den DSA wissen, was vielleicht auch nicht so bekannt ist
und was sollte man vielleicht lieber auch einfach vergessen?
Oder ein Verein wie der GFS und sozusagen Arbeit von Leuten wie dir überlassen.
Also man sollte wissen, dass wir jetzt zum ersten Mal Rechte haben,
um uns gegen Handlungen der Plattform zu wehren und die sollte man nutzen.
Und das geht am allerbesten tatsächlich, denke ich, wenn man sich ein bisschen
Hilfe sucht und unter anderem eben Organisationen wie auf die GFF zukommt und uns anspricht.
Und es gibt auch und ich glaube es ist auch wichtig, es gibt neue Transparenz
und neuen Zugang zu Daten und das sollten wir auch nutzen.
Also auch im Netzgeg gab es einen Anspruch auf Forschungsdatenzugang,
der nie genutzt wurde, aus verschiedenen Gründen, aber trotzdem,
jetzt haben wir den und jetzt müssen wir ihn auch nutzbar machen und deswegen
auch hier ein Aufruf an alle, die in der,
Forschungswiegesellschaft sind oder in irgendeiner Uni und Lust haben,
auf Sachen zu forschen, jetzt ist der Moment, um nachzudenken,
was für Daten wollt ihr eigentlich, wie könnte man die herkriegen und da aktiv zu werden.
Ich glaube, das ist mein Hauptappell.
Jetzt ist es da, lass uns nutzen und das Beste draus machen und die Sachen,
die nicht gut laufen, dann auch angehen und im Zweifelsfall auch gerecht überprüfen
lassen, ob manche Sachen eigentlich legitim sind, manche Artikel, manche nicht.
Ja, es gibt auf jeden Fall viel zu tun und auch viel Spielraum,
der uns da gegeben wurde.
Vielen Dank, dass du da warst und wir jetzt mal zum Ende dieses leidentlichen
Gesetzgebungsprozess gekommen sind.
Und ja, vielen Dank. Vielen Dank euch.
Wir werden uns ein neues Thema zum nächsten Mal überlegen. Das bereiten wir aber noch gleich.
Ja, das hat ja nicht so viel mit Gesetzgebung zu tun. Also wir bemühen uns ja
hier in Bettige Bretter immer so ein bisschen um diese Policy-Arbeit.
Also von der glaube ich auch jetzt relativ viel auch nochmal so zwischen den Inhalten durchkam.
Ja, also ich glaube vielleicht machen wir nochmal ein Ask me anything,
wie ist es eigentlich für die Kommission zu arbeiten.
Jederzeit. Das an einer anderen Stelle.
Ich glaube jetzt haben wir die Gehirne wieder genug verknotet und damit bis zum nächsten Mal.
Und vielen Dank. Danke euch. Ciao, ciao.
Music.